monsieur ma fille a donc vous avez la
retrouver ça arrive à l'ennemi je sais
je suis pas encore complètement gars que
tu vends vous savez bien ça fait trois
mois je travaille ici
faites un petit effort comment je
m'appelle
non me bats pas tu peux pas accepter
l'idée d'avoir besoin de quelqu'un parce
que moi je peux pas je travaille là tu
sais je crois qu'elle est bonne non peut
être et les geler ses deux beaux-fils
nouveaux projets annoncés l'eau du lac
elle n'est pas doué pour le bonheur un
an vous vous trompez ans carole pour les
coups c'est sûr mais se relève tout de
suite j'aimerais savoir comment ça se
passe au lit avec votre mari sa part
commencé avec ça quel genre de caresses
vous pouvez faire ça tu dois vous
prévenir mon père aime pas trop d'idée
d'avoir quelqu'un pour l'aider
vous avez eu tort de prendre cette place
elle va pas durer longtemps c'est bien
quand vous allez mourir
j'ai l'habitude avec la personne vieille
quelle chance nous
ça suffit
je trouve que tu organises toute ta vie
pour lui autour de lui et qui se rend
compte de rien
et
j'aime bien votre papa pourrais tu veux
pas le mettre dans cette résidence je
peux paraître avec ça
oui
cette fille a intéressé et toupie
d'habitat mais arrête maintenant tu fais
chier ce ski pas son papa des choses
comme ça vous savez quoi adopté je vous
laisse vous avez vu la chaux-de-fonds